we went out to uh rev major for the
philippines
oh man that event is awesome you see i
mean tekken fans all over the world and
just seeing how how into the game they
are just it's just a sight to see in
philippines has one of the best
communities when it comes to just love
protection
by far you know i was like always
jealous when you guys were there when i
saw it on the the streams like the first
year you and steve went and everyone's
like crowded around you guys at the
commentary table and everything i was
like damn that event looks cool and you
know i'd heard everyone talking about
how crazy it was but when i went there
myself i still wasn't prepared i was not
prepared yeah it was crazy about the
philippines
yeah it's crazy it's very very awesome i
definitely definitely want to go back
there without a doubt that was the best
but here we go losers matches continue
well droopy's using fang now yeah
switching it up and yeah
earlier that's the flavor of the of
season four so far fenway i mean it's
it's not the wrong way i'll tell you
that
it's the fang way all the way yep
here we go tempo step i get oh with the
second eight he wasn't ready that's a
high
yup
here we go
i haven't seen anyone use that up for
three plus four string
since i was testing the move list out
for tekken 5.
you're just saying you're saying this
yeah
i was like oh that was useless
oh here we go
yeah and that that back kepler stuff was
so strong in the early days of tekken 7
right they actually slowed down a little
bit
because i remember specifically
it was uh jdcr versus neat in the
philippines
and uh you know it would be dragging off
running
and he would kenpo step it wow
yeah finn gets off the ground weird man
you got to be ready for that but that
was also slightly off axis he has a jet
pack he got a little jet pack on him
anyways droopy with this change oh okay
that is not safe and that again was both
of those moves were not that was crazy
interesting sequence there x-star has to
be on point here
i like that forward three into down back
three that was a really good mix
oh okay
okay he he got greedy with that and
finally he got punished for it nice
nuts and you know one of the big things
i'm noticing too goopy he likes buttons
dude you know we saw him as a horn
player a second ago and now he's fang
he's very buzzy right so that backwards
butts oh yeah buttons yes he likes
buttons
he likes lots of buttons
i like big buttons and i cannot lie oh
three rounds straight for droopy
man um you know he had some momentum
there but again we've seen extar in this
situation before where he would go down
and he'd have to make some adjustments
and make a comeback can he do it again
as the hero of the loser's bracket
timeline will he be able to come back
this time the king here he wears a cape
for a reason you know uh we'll see if he
can get it done here though uh i think
groupie he's playing like a man like
who's upset about his loss from the
winner's side of the bracket you know
he's like he's got a statement to make
that's what i'm feeling right now out of
him uh out of seeing the way he
approached that matchup with his fang
right so
i'm feeling like droopy he's ready to
move on to this top four ready to bring
it all the way back to whoever sent him
down here in the first place
so i think you know we've had we've had
a lot of fun x-star so far but this is
definitely an uphill battle here this is
a test and and again there there's
obviously seems to be some intel there
because droopy not using warang who we
saw earlier today uh he's went straight
to fang and he dominated it was three
rounds straight it's like he he knew
that this matchup would be in his favor
yeah he plays so fast too right like
he's constantly keeping you guessing and
then he's either like forcing your turn
like it's like oh is your turn now it's
gonna be a back ken for step or
backswing blow like you better be ready
for it right so he really likes having
control of the offensive flow of the
matchup so far uh we'll we'll see if
x-star can turn things around here and
you know going back to that first that
we saw with x-star there were no throws
again here you know and like these seem
to be the games that he loses and it's
probably like a feeling out process i
think he's one of those players that he
needs to go through some rounds see how
what the opponent is doing you know
before he can really start working his
game plan in
all right we'll see how the game plan
works out he's gonna of course stick to
king
and we're gonna go back into the matchup
this time random stage into the arena
all right let's see how this plays out
holy moly x-star has 11 000 wins
holy moly i don't think i've ever seen
anyone with that many wins eleven
thousand
well maybe he does play he plays online
for sure
damn a lot
time to use that that uh that experience
put it all together
did you get the wall yet he does doesn't
get the follow up it doesn't matter
rolling sobato
man he has the wall do something there
you go here we go
oh
he didn't go for the screw
yeah
he's gonna have to realize that last hit
is high
yeah he i mean definitely not a movie
you see a lot from penguin but oh the
back turn makes goes with the low this
time full launcher
groupie running away with this one
factor mix again wow that looks sideways
right that was weird yeah that was a
definitely an interesting uh situation
there now xo the whiff
into the low and look at that droopy
running away with it again uncontested
four rounds straight now
oh forward kenpo now
yeah really slowing things down here
[Music]
[Applause]
and they're now starting to use a little
bit more of the tool set here from
fenway that quarter circle forward one a
great approach move especially if your
opponent's not able to react to it
[Applause]
oh my gosh and he beat out the ford ford
one range by going for that reverse
kenpo into the launch looking to close
it out and right now jupiter is looking
way too good and there it is
shoulder iron mountain
for the finish two rounds to to none and
again that's five round straight right
now for droopy
yeah x-star gonna have to do something
drastic here to turn things around
faster makes nice back dash out late
no he's not he's not he's not getting
punched he's i don't know what x-star
what's going through his mind but he
needs to get some offense started
yeah i think he doesn't know how to
approach here right like
what is even the best approach to i mean
even like the fourth one maybe oh no
that would be that way
oh my gosh god that should have been a
hot kick oh no
not gonna happen x-star out at fifth
place droopy moving into the top four
and no he had a couple of chances there
that finally hit that round right that
toe kick whiffing if that was a hop kick
there that would have been perfect but
unfortunately not ready for it uh and
we'll be out of tournament fifth place
yeah very dominant though from his
opponent because